all:
HI.
- HEY.
- HI!
- HELLO?
OH, HI.
ARE YOU WITH THE BOUNCE HOUSE?
- OH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH,
I'M JEFF.
- OH, YOU ARE? OKAY.
WE HAVE A FRONT DOOR.
- OH, SURE.
- SO YOU'RE--
I'M SORRY, YOU'RE JE--
YOU'RE NOT JOHNNY THEN?
- NO, NO.
JOHNNY'S MY BROTHER.
HE KILLED HIMSELF, SO--
- HONEY!
- UM...
[clattering]
I THINK YOUR FENCE IS BROKEN.
- YEAH, IT'S NOT.
OR IT WASN'T.
BE CAREFUL.
I REALLY--
I DON'T WANT A LAWSUIT.
HONEY! UM, THAT'S--
- ALL RIGHT, KIDS!
ALL RIGHT, KIDS!
[children scream]
- [laughs wildly]
NOT WE'RE HAVING FUN ALREADY.
ALL RIGHT, OKAY.
SO IT'S BELLA'S BIRTHDAY,
SO SHE'S RUNNING THE SHOW.
IT'S ME...
AND THEN IT'S BELLA.
ALL RIGHT, THIS IS
THE MOST EXCITING PART. KIDS!
LOOK AT THIS.
- ALL RIGHT!
- COME TO LIFE.
YOU LOOK AT THIS HOUSE
GET FILLED WITH AIR
JUST LIKE I WATCHED THE AIR
LEAVE MY BROTHER'S BODY
WHEN HE KILLED HIMSELF
IN FRONT OF ME.
- YOU KNOW WHAT, JEFF?
- WHAT'S THAT, MOM?
- WE'RE GONNA MAYBE
NOT VISIT THAT TOPIC ANYMORE.
- WHAT'S THE SNACK SITUATION?
- MAKING REAL HEAVY
EYE CONTACT THERE, MAN.
- OH, YEAH.
- ARE YOU GAY?
- OH, WHAT ARE YOU SAYING? NO.
- IS THIS A--
- I'M NOT A--
NO, NO.
TRUST ME, I HAD PLENTY
OF OPPORTUNITIES IN PRISON
TO DO THAT,
BUT I DIDN'T.
OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
HEY, BELLA!
GIVE UNCLE JEFF
A PUSH IN THE TUSH.
IT'S UNCLE JEFF.
YOU GUYS ARE SITTING ON
WHERE MY BROTHER PASSED.
THIS IS A VIDEO.
YOU KNOW, THEY JUST--
KIDS LOVED HIM.
THEY WOULD JUST SWARM HIM.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T HAVE THAT,
UH, RELATIONSHIP WITH KIDS,
BUT YOU GUYS SEEM COOL.
WE SHOULD
LOCK DOWN PLANS.
- WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- OH, JUST HANGING OUT
WITH THE KIDS.
TELLING THEM STORIES.
- OKAY.
KIDS, YOU WANNA, UM--
WHO HAS TO GO TO THE BATHROOM?
- I DO.
- EVERYBODY, COME ON.
HERE COMES THE CAKE.
IT'S BELLA'S BIRTHDAY.
LET'S MAKE A WISH.
- WISH MY BROTHER
HADN'T KILLED HIMSELF.
- HUH?
- BUT, UH...
YOU KNOW, WHAT I ALSO
WISH FOR IS A NEW FAMILY.
AND I FEEL LIKE I--
[clears throat]
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE THAT
WITH YOU GUYS.
SO LET'S WISH FOR THAT.
- [under breath]
OH, MY GOD.